okay
we're ready to get started we hope
okay so the age of the ipad and i've got
these two images here one is a roman
lady with her wax tablet i think we'll
close the door here so we don't disturb
people and i'm sure many of you who did
latin at school or whatever know that
in roman times
the school children had little tablets
and whatever the master said presumably
they wrote that down and so to me the
roman tablet represents you know a
tablet which really can only receive
information or you can write yourself
but you can't share the information you
can't participate in much
whereas
with the ipad and this has certainly
been my experience all of a sudden you
are connected you are connected to a
huge community almost a limitless
community
and uh
we'll go to the next page here
and i happen to like learning languages
so in the last 10 years
i have been working on four languages
uh russian portuguese
cantonese and korean
the korean is not so hot
but the other three i managed quite
comfortably listen to the radio don't
have much trouble
so you are connected to the world and if
your interests are languages that's fine
if they're something else you can find
communities of people who have similar
interests
now
i had i was on a
i guess a
forum on the internet arguing with
someone this person was doom and gloom
and you know the world is in terrible
shape and you know
people are dying and they're sick and
just that
and i remember that there was a book
written by someone called the rational
optimist i couldn't remember the name of
the book
so i simply went to because i have an a
kindle application on my ipod i went to
kindle which takes me to amazon i just
put optimism
and up came this book the rational
optimist by matt ridley and yes that's
the book i won
and i bought it for seven dollars so i'm
sitting in my sofa at home i say i want
to read this book because it's relevant
to this discussion that i'm having
the optimist something or other optimist
i google or not i google i go to amazon
on my ipad i see the book i buy it and i
start reading it
i mean
sorry i mean to me that's absolutely
extraordinary
absolutely extraordinary it's not the
first time i've done it i had if uh you
know i wanna i often get into arguments
with people about education i can look
up what are people saying about
education here's a slew of books some of
them are very cheap 99 cents
buy it read it it's not a good book
throw it away you know nothing lost so
to me it's extraordinary now this book
the rational optimist is a very
interesting book
and the point that he makes is
that
evolution
of idea the evolution of ideas as
opposed to our evolution that you know
physiologically right
the evolution of ideas takes place when
we have a competition of different ideas
and exchange of ideas not the same ideas
but different as in
in trade for example we don't exchange
wine for wine we exchange
economics at school
it's the portuguese wine for the british
wool or whatever it was it's this whole
idea of comparative advantage and so the
more exchange of ideas we have and the
more competition of ideas we have
the better ideas come forward the poor
ideas don't survive and this is all
cumulative and we accumulate this
tremendous collective knowledge i'm
simplifying his book i'm giving you this
book in 30 seconds here
but with this we can customize to
different needs as an anarchic bottom-up
development but the net result is
that
our collective knowledge grows and the
bigger the community and the greater the
amount of exchange and the greater the
exchange of ideas
the faster we develop and so really
this this development is accelerating
so if we look at
just in terms of information technology
i think the first pc i can remember
playing this funny game uh on a pc in
1980 you know and i think the internet
really didn't get going until 1995. i
mean it's only been around for 15 years
uh wikipedia which is everybody's first
place to look up anything
uh only came on in 2001. now you can say
that it's not always accurate but
there's always something there and you
can skip wikipedia but it is there and
if we have an argument how many people
live there or whatever
it's there and it's free and it's only
been around since 2001. if we look at
the speed with which we can access these
different systems i mean i can remember
standing in japan selling lumber
connecting on a public telephone taking
forever you know so that i can send
information but i can work in the rain
whatever and now we have here i am
i am standing here and i'm connected
and that's all happened in
in a very very short space of time and
so the more people are connected the
more the ideas are being developed and
the faster these things are
are accelerating uh if we look at this
you know we used to deal with mainframe
computers desktop
laptop ipad iphone everything's getting
smaller
uh
even the content is merging now you know
radio uh
internet telephone skype communicate
it's all merging into one it's
extraordinary you'll be able to to dial
into whatever like i can sit at home
on my
apple
and i can go to a radio station and i
can look up classical music and up opens
up you know 100 radio stations and i
want to there's radio chopin there's
radio mozart there's barack whatever i
want i pick one that happens to be a
radio station out of geneva
uh i have in my house i got a little
repeater station for my
for my
network
and i have speakers on there
and so just before i sit down for
breakfast on a sunday morning i like
barack music with my breakfast
so before we sit down i just pop in a
radio station we listen to baroque music
while we have breakfast it's
extraordinary if i wanted to listen to
portuguese photos i could find them so
uh so all of this stuff is happening
and uh
just to get back to
our friend the rational optimist
in this whole attitude of doom and gloom
he points out in fact that since 1970
the population of the world is doubled
now for some people they may not think
that's nice but for those people who
wouldn't otherwise be alive it's not a
bad deal right i mean there's 7 billion
people alive maybe there would only have
been one billion without all this
progress so for the six billion who have
a chance to live
that's kind of
positive
uh cereal productions double despite all
the gloom and doom poverty has declined
health has improved
prices for everything have declined in
terms of how many hours or days of work
are required to purchase something
the only exception is education
and in the united states
the price the cost of k-12 kindergarten
grade 12 education
in
constant dollars has gone up 350
since the 1960s
350 in constant dollars and the results
are at best the same
i mean there is a statistic it's not
directly but it's largely related to
education the incarceration rate in the
united states has gone up 700 percent
since the 1960s
so
i believe what about housing housing
housing is marginally you know housing
has across the building house or the
cost of land buying a house okay well
you have to look at the price of land
now the price plan again i'm not an
expert on this but it tends to rise
fairly positive the cost of building a
house he mentions in this book is
somewhat less than it was let's say 100
years ago but it's not as dramatically
less as a number of things including
food and so on
so i have to believe that the ipad is is
part of and when i talk about the age of
the ipad i think i think the ipad is is
only the beginning you know there will
be other tablets but the idea that many
many people are going to be connected in
a mobile convenient way to these vast
communities where people are exchanging
information ideas languages you name it
that that's going to finally bring some
of these
cost savings to education
because if we look at a classroom